hey guys my name is Jess McDonald today
is the 17th of March and your change
into games for years
Nintendo dropped a bunch of news today
including their plans to develop from
verbal and a new upcoming systems
Nintendo has signed a deal with Japanese
mobile games publisher DNA which
includes the agreements for new gaming
applications featuring Nintendo IP being
created specifically for smart devices
Nintendo have said they will not be
restricting the use of their IP for
mobile platforms so expect to see your
favorite Nintendo alum on your phone
eventually at a press conference today
chief exec Satoru Iwata also revealed
the Nintendo's new dedicated games
platform is in development codenamed and
X
iwasa didn't expand on it further only
saying it represented a brand new
concept he also said it was being
developed in tandem with Nintendo's new
digital membership service which unlike
the former Club Nintendo program will
encompass existing core hardware systems
as well as smart devices and PC Nvidia
have revealed the specs and pricing of
their brand-new super power 12 gigabyte
GTX Titan X so here's what you can
expect 900 and a 99 bucks will buy you
the first GPU from Nvidia to come with
12 gigabytes of vram when it hits
shelves tomorrow
as for the nitty gritty stuff the Titan
X has a 384 bit memory interface which
shifts data 50% faster at three hundred
and thirty six point five gigabytes a
second it also makes use of the GM 200
core for the first time which carries a
billion transistors in a 28 millimeter
die all in all it's the absolute best PC
graphics card that a lot of money can
buy and finally a bunch more mortal
kombat x characters have leaked today
though here's whose ass you'll get to
kick come April new gameplay screenshots
popped up on Xbox achievements dot-com
giving us a glimpse of what we can
assume are a few more playable
characters newcomer aaron black as well
as series regulars Jax
goro shinik and Baraka all feature in
the leaked images suggesting that
there's a good chance these are five
more dudes who skull inside you'll get
to see very soon since Nintendo already
brought us the analog stick touchscreen
and motion controls let me know what you
think they new concept is gonna be for
the NX you can edge against that or
we've got news on a crazy GTA hype
achievement and the Xbox one swing TV
app those are all the things that I
wanted to tell you about today as always
thanks for stopping by it leave me your
thoughts and I'll catch you same time
tomorrow